welcome back guys to design patterns
today we're going to be looking at some
State patterns and how you can use them
in your code so if you're engineering a
new project then this would be a good
thing to add so we're going to go ahead
and just start our normal way and add a
place for this I'm just going to call it
State and of course we've got to get a c
make and all that in there
and we will add a main make sure we got
our cmake updated so that it makes sense
let's call this state
state
and update our top level cmake to
include it there we go now we should get
that added and available to run we're
going to make a state.h here in a second
and this will just be our client code to
test it out essentially
let's go ahead and make the state.h now
a lot of times I haven't really added
the edit files here the executable but
technically you should so uh just be
aware of that when you're engineering
your software my fellow software
Engineers I'm going to say that a lot
and you guys are in the Discord will
know why
but uh video on that probably Wednesday
all right so state
let's think about this a little bit what
do you want to do with a state a state
typically design some sort of situation
that your program is in and it should do
some certain thing so essentially we
need a way to to handle these states to
begin with and
so essentially we want some sort of
initial engine all right in our case
we're going to call this well we could
call it context we could call it engine
I'm going to call it engine I like the
idea of calling a ninja so I'm going to
just do a little forward declare because
our states are going to need to know
about engines because we're going to
also store a little back reference in
our states so that states can uh
also call back to the engine to change
State that'll make more sense shortly
here
all right so let's go ahead and just uh
make a a base state so this is going to
be the
your virtual State here
and let's make a protected section here
and just add in an engine pointer now
this is not owned by the state so we're
not going to ever delete it or anything
like that we just want to have a
potential reference to it in case we
want to change it later and we want to
do all our standard public stuff that we
need
a deleter there and I will clean up the
syntax here in a second and also
so if we want to potentially be able to
edit the engine in what state it's in
we're going to have to put in a method
for that and it's going to be pretty
simple it'll just be something like this
set and we'll call it set engine and
it's going to take an engine pointer so
all that's going to do uh let's make
these some some other name uh we'll just
make this
with an underscore so that way we can uh
there and just set it equal to the new
engine now the states essentially do
some sort of work
uh so we need to put something in here
for that and uh we'll make it a virtual
and we'll just say I don't know what
kind of work do we want to do it totally
depends on what kind of software you're
building or engineering so I'm just
going to say do work pay or yeah let's
do a work a
and we'll set this to equal zero and
maybe we have it do work B here
so that's something we're going to have
to uh to build all right so let's let's
work up our engine a little bit here so
let's make another class we'll call it
engine
and
engine is going to hold member reference
well not a member pointer to one of
these states so State pointer State and
then here publicly we just want to have
some functions to to operate on the
state we do want a Constructor we never
want to have our engine net not have any
state make this underscore state so we
definitely want a Constructor at least
in our case depends what you're doing
you might do it slightly differently but
we're going to make a little Constructor
here that takes a state pointer
and we'll initialize state to null
pointer
even in this case because well sure you
could initialize it right here we're
going to do a couple other things just
to give it a little control for example
we're going to instead make a method
here in a moment called we're going to
call it transition so essentially
anytime you want to change State you're
going to have that available so we're
just going to use that function so I'm
just going to go ahead and type it up
here transition
two and then state
all right very good we need some kind of
Destructor here because as we'll see
this engine actually has ownership of
these states so it will also delete them
so call delete state
both the engine goes out of content or
goes out of scope or whatever you delete
it it's also going to delete any states
Associated this may or may not be
required depending on what you're doing
if you want your states to live longer
and exist even when your context
goes out of scope maybe you have several
engines and you want to keep your States
alive then you don't want to do this but
it in our example we're going to have
our engine own these states because
they're essentially going to take
control of them
all right so let's make our transition
to function here and of course it takes
a state pointer to call these lowercase
State and now we want to put some stuff
in here so if there's already a state or
if it's already not null essentially so
we'll say if state
then we do want to delete it and we
delete the state so that just
you know just starting off if we're
going to transition to another one we
want to get rid of the old one at least
for our particular case here so that
looks good and then we want to set up
our new one so we'll just basically set
it equal just like so there's our
private Member One set it to the one
we're transitioning to so Constructor
we'll just call this and take care of
everything right off but there's one
other thing we want to do here we want
to call from the state we want to call
set engine so that it has a back
reference to the engine and this is so
when we make our do work later Sometimes
some of these work functions will have a
transition and that way we'll be able to
reference the engine and call a
transition to set up other states so I
know that probably sounds like a little
confusing at first but it'll make more
sense shortly here so essentially we
just want to go State set
engine and we want to set it to this
current class that we're building so
that's it that's all we need for our
transition now of course we need some
way in our engine to operate on these so
we would essentially build some more
functions and it's going to delegate
some of its Behavior to these states
so the states could be anything they
could be you know anything that might do
some work or be some sort of Delegation
of work
for now I'm just gonna kind of do some
sort of reference of these but you'll
probably get a little more creative with
whatever you happen to be engineering
with your software my fellow software
Engineers all right
so I'm just going to say request a and
just set
or call from the state to work a
and you could add more to it of course
but that's signed for now
well we don't really need any more
actually because this particular State
it's got a reference to the engine so if
it's got some logic in it to change the
state it can do that because of this
back reference there and same with all
these so this is a super cool setup and
we'll just keep filling it out there all
right very good so we've got our engine
set up there that takes different states
and can do transitions it's got a little
back reference but now we need some
actual States because of course this one
is pure virtual so that being pure
virtual is not something we can
instantiate so we just need to make some
actual real States here that do stuff
so let's go ahead and do that yeah we'll
just do let's see what do we want to
call them
I don't know I can't think of anything
great I'm just going to go off the
example I'm looking at is called this
concrete State a of course
and inherit from State and we just want
to override all the methods that need
overridden um which is going to be these
here so let's just copy those down for
the moment and
we're going to go ahead and Define them
in this header so we just don't need
this virtual word we're just going to
have
override here of course and then it's
whatever it does and I suppose now would
be a good time to be able to have some
sort of output so let's go ahead and up
here just put IO stream included that
way we can do stuff with the console
and show that it's actually functioning
here shortly
all right so what do we want work a to
do I don't know we don't really have
that much specific design here in this
case it's just an example so we're just
going to say
um
yeah we'll just say the class
and maybe what it's doing or something
like that so instead of manually typing
these out we could just use a little
type ID trick let's mess around with
that a bit sure why not so we're going
to include type info and we're just
going to say uh let's see
we're going to use the type ID function
and we're going to use it on this so
that should say concrete State a
basically
and then we're just going to say the
function here we get our spacing right
and we'll just say a
that should be fine and we'll just do a
similar thing for for B for now
so that way we'll be able to see when
they're called and let's just make a
second one because yeah we want to have
an example of of several States here so
let's just uh make a concrete State B
copy this down for now and just fix up a
few things and now we're going to do a
few interesting things here this should
automatically say State B because of
this type ID thing but let's try another
little trick here
where we're gonna change the context say
maybe State B if you call work a
maybe it transitions to concrete State a
so we could do that by going
uh see what do we call it engine so the
states have a protected member engine
pointer that is definitely that should
be set
because when we set it with this
transition to it sets it there
so we should be able to go engine
and then transition to and whatever we
want now of course if you have one
already in memory you can just pass that
pointer there but if you want to make a
new one you can just construct it even
right here so we could just construct
concrete
State a here and that would
so it would do work and then transition
all right so after this transition the
next time you call do work a it should
call this one here makes sense so
essentially you can flip your states
around as you need you know you build
all the states you want you have them do
the things they need to do and you have
them transition as they need to and
that's essentially
all you need to know to get the state
stuff working for your software so let's
do some examples and just show it
actually working so let's go over to our
main
and just fill out a few things well
first of all
let's see here of course we need an
engine and we're gonna need some some of
those States so let's just go engine I
don't know we'll call it engine one all
right probably I don't know I guess it
could be a pointer doesn't really matter
I guess in this case but these engines
if we go look at now their bill
requires a pointer to a new state so we
could just do that right in line here
with new and we need any of these states
that we've implemented let's use
concrete State let's use concrete State
B in this case so we can show that
transition and then we could just start
calling stuff so we would just go engine
one dot uh Quest a and or of course
request a we'll do the work for a we
know that on concrete State B it's going
to end up transitioning so if we call
this twice in a row we should
essentially get well the concrete State
B call do work a and then a transition
and when we call it again we should see
a so hopefully that all makes sense but
let's go ahead and just give it a run
switch this to state with the Run button
and let's see if we get that nope we've
got an error so let's see what we've got
here
oh just a little bit of error with this
type ID to get it as a cons care array
you're going to do dot name so that's it
so you know actually up at the top here
I'm just going to make a quick
Define I know this is going to be bad uh
we're just going to call it ID name
Define ID name as this whole thing
I think this will work yeah
uh we'll call it uh just call it class
name all right so we're going to Define
class name to go type ID this dot name
all right and that's just going to allow
us to type this word instead of that
whole thing every time which you know
you don't need to do necessarily but I
just want to be able to make this look
nice and clean in this regard
cool all right now let's try this again
all right seems pretty happy seems to
have done what we think uh class
concrete State B uh
okay I don't know why this pointer
thing's here but that's fine it's not
going to hurt anything just part of that
dot name I suppose uh called do work a
and then of course after that transition
concrete State a did it now we didn't
make this super verbal we could put more
C outs to Define what everything's doing
but that's essentially it you can build
up this pattern as required as you
engineer your software and it should
help you out a little bit I would not
recommend doing this whole defined thing
here I'm just kind of goofing around
there but hopefully that all makes sense
if you have any questions let me know
down below and uh stay tuned for more
more software engineering content thanks
for tuning in guys we'll see in the next
one peace out
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]